gentlemen, their Excellencies the President of
Ukraine Volodymyr Zelenskyi and the
President of the European Commission Ms.
Ursula
Fonderlein statement of the President of
Ukraine
Thank you, dear
Ursula, dear
journalists, all
present would like to welcome to Ukraine today
Madam
President Queer European Commissioner
Urslufonderlein this visit is taking place at a
historic moment, a very important moment, a
moment when we are waiting for a political
decision regarding  of Ukraine on the start of
negotiations on the membership of our country in the
European Union, this decision will have a
turning point in the history of not only
Ukraine, but also the whole of Europe. When we
start negotiations on the membership of Ukraine,
I believe in it very much. And it will mean
several fundamental things: first, there will
be no more gray geopolitical  zones in Europe,
secondly, we will provide a new basis for
the growth of Ukraine and all European
countries, and thirdly, we will guarantee our
state and the Ukrainian people real
economic and social security, a
security that corresponds to our values ​​and the
values ​​of Europeans, even during a
full-scale war, Ukraine does
not stop on the way to what the
state needs  reforms, we clearly understand that
membership in the European Union is a recognition of the
respective institutional development of
each country and is based on specific
merits in protecting European rules of
life, that is why Ukraine does not ask for
concessions on the way to the European Union.
for the start of
negotiations on membership, we implemented
this also applies to the rule of law and the
protection of human rights and freedoms of
national communities and greater
transparency in the work of state institutions,
links and posts and the strengthening of the
strengthening of our state, the strengthening of the
anti-corruption
infrastructure, but
Ukraine does not stop
the transformation of our institutions, the
reforms will be continued in particular  we have
prepared new legislation that
will give the anti-corruption system
the ability to work effectively; the
corresponding bill on the
specialized anti-corruption
prosecutor's office has already been registered in the
Verkhovna Rada of Ukraine; we are also preparing a
bill on lobbyism that will add
transparency to the political process and
reliably protect the state from the
destructive influence of oligarchs and other
persons who try to circumvent the rule of
law  we are also working towards the
digitization of state services and the very
work of state state institutions,
this is a path that is important for us, a path of
maximum transparency and
efficiency of the state system. Ukraine
will be as ready as possible for the start of
negotiations with the European Union regarding accession and
consent to full membership in the EU.
Today, we
discussed with Ms.  president, also the
question of specific support for Ukraine and
our society in protecting against
Russian aggression is very important that
the support of Europe and our other
partners remained stable and
reliable, this also applies to defense and
financial support, Russia must
see that the world does not
back down in defending freedom and
international law, and I thank you very much
Ursula, for understanding this, of course, it is worth
continuing our joint work and
so that Russian assets in
various jurisdictions around the world, and in particular in
Europe, also work to protect against
Russian aggression, and this is important in the end.
which are related to it, to
compensate for all the damage caused by the
war, I thank our European
partners for finding appropriate legal
steps,
another issue is the issue of sanctions, and this is the
preparation of a new EU sanctions package,
we are very, very much expecting, counting on
it, and preventing the circumvention of
existing Russian  sanctions, in particular, because of the
European company and the territory of the
neighboring states of Russia, the sanctions must
work at 100% so that this war ends as soon as possible with a
real victory for Ukraine,
Ukraine and all of Europe, our common
European
home.
to be
back in Ki We had a very good meeting UM
and we have discussed indeed many important
topics I want to have a Look at Three
Points That I want to highlight Here
First and most important of course is
ukraine's accession Path to the European
Union I must  say you have Made excellent
Progress This is impressive to see We
Will testify to this Next week UM When
The commission Will Present Its Report
on
enlargement I want to tell you How
impressed We are By the reforms you've
made in the midst of a War you should
Never forget You are Fighting an
existential War and at the same time
You're deeply reforming your country you
have reached many
milestones reforming your Justice System
curbing The oligarchs Grip tackling
Money laundering and much more This is
the result of Hard Work and I know that
you are in the process of completing
outstanding reforms if this Happens and
I'm confident Ukraine can reach Its
ambitious Goal of Moving to the Next
Stage in the accession process this will
also be my message this afternoon in
the My Second Point is you have Made
very important Steps Forward In Your
economic
modernization You Are reconstructing You
are modernizing the
country We have supported you so far
with almost 83 billion euros and Ukraine
is said to receive further 3 billion
euros Still this year but of course more
and predictable funding is necessary to
meet The current needs so The commission
has proposed to the member States 50
billion euros until 2027 in additional
Support to make this Work We are
together developing The Ukraine Plan
this will Aim to further modernize your
country through reforms and
Investments so The Ukraine Plan is Key
To Access The 50 billion euros there has
been very good Progress and now We have
to work hard to get it over the Finish
Line in the Next few
One Good example of our Work on keeping
the economy Running are the solidarity
lanes They have so far allowed  Ukraine
to export over 100 Million tons of Goods
more than Half of these 100 Million tons
of Goods are agrifood Products so
Ukraine is Feeding the world in these
times of
scarcity and of course in addition the
solidarity lanes bring much needed
revenues back to Ukraine in the  last 16
months This is the time Frame Since When
We have the solidarity lanes this has
already brought revenues of 42 billion
Back to
Ukraine In this context I would like to
commend Ukraine for Its efforts to
reestablish Navigation On The Black Sea
more grain Can Leave on  these two rotes
Ukraine but nevereless We need The
solidarity lanes Around 65% of the
Ukrainian agrifood Products Leave the
country Via these solidarity lanes and
This is also Why we are heavily
investing and reinforcing these lanes
This is Rail and Road and border
crossings last year We  have pledged 1
billion of investment and it is good
that this amount has already been
exceeded So every effort every Europe is
Well invested Because it anchors The
Ukrainian economy in our Single Market
My Third and Final Point
is we will continue to make Russia Pay
For Its  War of Aggression our existing
sanctions have deeply affected the
Russian economy and very soon we will
propose to member States our 12th
package of sanctions there will be New
listings to Hold accountable those Who
are involved in the Military Invasion
and occupation of the
also those Who are  involved in the
brutal abduction of children and those
Who are involved in Fake News and
propaganda furthermore The sanctions
package Will include New import and
export bans and It includes actions To
tighten The oil Price Cap and finally we
will further Crack Down on sanctions
circumvention In All  these topics We are
very closely coordinating with our G7
partners overall Russia has to Pay a
Price for the devastation and the
Destruction It has caused and In this
context There is Another example This is
the topic of the proceeds of the 200
billion Euro of immobilized Russian
sovereign assets in Europe They are the
proceeds are accumulating every day so
We believe that these profits should Go
in rebuilding Ukraine and This is Why
The commission Will Now very soon come
with a proposal that allows this to
happen finally Mr President deadomir The
peace Formula meeting  in malta sent an
important message of engagement we will
continue to Support and promote a just
and lasting peace For Ukraine This is
Our common Goal and Rest assured that
our Support is unshakable Thank you,
dear journalists, your questions please
financial times the first
will be hen financial times  Thank you for
the opportunity Mr President UH Later
Next month You will Ask European Union
leaders to agree To A 50 billion
financial package For Ukraine and to
Start accession talks have the
conversations
withident Made
moreident You'll gre
for both and also How concerned are you
By the War In the middle East Changing
The Focus of the European Union away
from Ukraine and to madam President UM
You just said that there would be a
proposal on using The Frozen assets very
soon we've Heard you say that before
Could you quantify very  soon could It Be
By the end of the year and secondly
there are Media reports this morning
that EU and US officials have been
pressuring Ukraine to think about the
outlines of potential peace negotiations
are you aware of Such talks and Would
you
first of all I am very  I am glad about our
dialogue today with Madam
President. I believe that, from our side,
in addition to the gratitude of the European Union to the
EU countries that have constantly supported us
throughout this difficult time, and in addition to our
really very warm relations, strong
relations with Ursula, there are very clear things, there are
seven recommendations, there are different voices in the EU,
this  Of course, everyone has the right to their
opinion, but there are seven recommendations and our
task is to implement all seven recommendations. I am
not saying that, I repeat once again that we
will stop at these seven
recommendations, this is part of the many
reforms that Ukraine is really ready and will
continue, and frankly, we want  it is
very important for us to do this, to bring
all the reforms to the end, but regarding the opening of
negotiations, we must fulfill what is
written, we will do it.
And I believe that after this there can be a
positive result for us, a very very
valuable result for Ukraine, a very
motivating result for society  a
very motivating result for all
the soldiers who defend these values ​​at the front,
and all this is very important. Yes, and to
continue our
struggle for independence, it is important, and that is
why it is such a weapon, it is different, but it is
important and this weapon We must bring to
our
society, that is why I believe in it  very strongly
regarding the Middle East, I will answer
you, it is
clear, the war in the Middle East, this
conflict is taking away the focus. I believe that this is
one of the goals of the Russian
Federation,
understanding that the
focus will be on Ukraine.
it is based on the
results, but everything is within our power. We have
already been in difficult situations. We have
already been in a very difficult situation when there
was no focus on Ukraine, almost it was from the
media, but it was not from world leaders, and
yet we were able to get out of this situation, so
I absolutely  are we sure about
this
challenge about conversations I think this is a
question for Ursula but I will allow myself
to answer a little if you don't mind okay
about conversations
look I don't know who is
posting this I don't know why this is
being done I don't have a very unpleasant
feeling
that even we  Ukrainians in the media also
support this topic. I am surprised by this. The
United States, especially these signals that the
Narmsteins were discussed that we will
talk in one way or another. I don't
know with Russia, I don't know who is doing it,
but I, as a
person,
have this responsibility.  and
authority regarding certain negotiations,
I will answer you very frankly, everyone knows that
my attitude coincides with the attitude of
Ukrainian society, and that is why no one is putting
pressure on me today, at first, all this was at the
beginning of the war and before the war, to
this day, no one is putting pressure on me from the
leaders of the EU United  States,
etc. among our partners so that we now
sit down and talk with Russia and give her something, this
will not happen
with your 10p peace Formula UH
with the National Security advisors
First in copenhagen then in jedda Now in
malta UH so it shows that UM you Taking
initiative while Fighting  a War UM to
have your territorial Integrity and to
keep your sovereignty supported by US
on the windfall profits Yes I can
confirm that we will come with a
proposal before The End of the years the
year
Thank you second and last question
Interfax Ukraine
please have a good
day  the first question of the President of
Ukraine to the public was an
article by Valery Zaluzhnyi published in the journal "Legislator" in
which, talking about
the war, he wrote that it had moved from a
positional stage to a
maneuver stage,
and that
this was a protracted process.
Do you think from this thread, were
these ideas of Valery Zaluzhnyi discussed
at the pond, for example, and what
steps Ukraine needs to take now in
order to make a technological
breakthrough, and the second question to the
president of the European Commission
AA, please tell me if you know about the
difficult debates in the congress  of the United
States regarding the support of Ukraine for the
next year, do you have any
contacts with the administration of the United
States or with the opposition or, more
precisely, the Republican majority in the
House of Representatives
regarding the order and volume of
aid to Ukraine in 2024, or can
Europe simply lend a hand in this regard
?  is it called whether to
help Ukraine in the event that
the aid of the United States is
reduced,
thank you, thank you for the question,
you know, remember on the
24th, she told us all
how much
we had left.
there we will already solve this
issue and almost the whole country will soon be
captured and Kyiv will be and there were various
signals of conditions, etc. we must give everything to the
people change Russia recognize Europe
forget about NATO don't think about So and what is
Ukraine does not have such a
state of all
these voices I  I have heard a lot over the years,
and I was absolutely sure of us. We
were in a more difficult situation in which,
for sure, Ukraine
was never restored to independence, but we believed very much
and fought and
won today, time has passed, people are
tired, everyone is tired and there are different opinions
on this  all people, all people are independent
of their status and that is clear, there is
nothing like that here,
but this is not a deadlock situation, I
emphasize this once again, we have already talked about it, this is
not some kind of news,
Russia controls the sky in offensive
missions, this is clear, if we protect
our military, we  let's take care of the boys and
girls when they control the sky, it's easy to
throw like Russia throws
its people like meat, no one wants to. How to overcome this
f16 there
is a solution.
Air defenses, we tried it,
when there is an anti-aircraft missile at the front, everyone clearly understands that
the military is moving forward, running, driving,
using equipment, and some
counter-offensive actions are underway. We were in a
difficult, very difficult situation a year ago, and now in a
stalemate, everyone said in a
stalemate, everything is simple, everyone has forgotten
a few
sure, and the tactics of military operations,
and you remember the Kharkiv region was
liberated, and you remember what
happened in
Kherson, that's why there are
difficulties, there are different opinions, different opinions, that's how it
is.
tell me what is
the alternative, what is the alternative,
we must understand what the
alternative is, yes, we must protect
our people,
the fact, but what is the alternative, what is necessary, well,
then we must give up a third of our state, this will
only be the beginning, but it will not end with this,
we know that  such a frozen
conflict, we have drawn conclusions for ourselves,
why do you and I return
to one or another opinion or format. Therefore, we
must all come together, come together strongly,
and solve the issue, work more
with partners on air defense, unblock the sky,
give our troops the opportunity to take
offensive actions, appropriate offensive
actions  That's what you need to think about, only about
this, not about where we will be tomorrow, but
now
Thank you also in Military capabilities of
course It is a domestic and sovereign
decision of the United States How to
proceed But when We have talks with the
United States for example I think  two or
three weeks ago UH We had The EU US
Summit We are reporting on UH our Share
How we're working on that and of course
I was reporting on the 50 billion That I
proposed to the European Council and
that we're working hard  to have it
agreed Till The End of the year so The
exch
Thank you This is the end of the press conference
thank you
all right
[music]
Thank